"Mickey Mouse and the Three Musketeers"
That is... pretty much exactly what you get.
Mickey, Donald, and Goofy all going off to save Princess Minnie so that evil Captain Pete
can't take over the crown. Yeah, somehow kidnapping her makes him king...
This isn't really story-based.
The plot is... hmm... wait, no, that was pretty much it.
Yeah, it's about as generic and old-fashioned a cartoon plot for kids goes.
So, is it any good?
(Uncertain mumbling)
I... well, it's...
hard to pick on something that's obviously meant for, like, *little*, little kids.
I mean it's a Mickey Mouse direct-to-DVD movie.
What do you expect?
Well, but, again, I guess that's not fair;
Mickey's been in some really good stuff.
There's a great short he was in called "The Prince and the Pauper".
"Fantasia" is a masterpiece. Even that "Mickey's Once Upon a Christmas" had a lot of charm to it.
This, I don't really describe as a having a lot of charm, but it's... harmless.
Every character and motivation is exactly what you think it's gonna be.
Mickey is optimistic, but he dreams of being a "Mouseketeer".
(sigh) Did I really just say that? You know what I mean.
Goofy is a doofus, but he wants to apply his brain.
Donald is a coward and wants to learn how to be brave.
And Minnie is a princess, so, of course, she wants to fall in love.
There is nothing new or original in this.
Even the songs are classical, public domain tunes that they just put lyrics to.
Some of them already have lyrics. They just add new ones.
I guess it's good this teaches kids classical music, but it's music you're gonna hear everywhere, anyway,
and I don't know...
The animation is clearly trying, and the backgrounds are clearly trying, but nothing really stands out as... great.
Everybody does exactly what you think they do. Everybody reacts exactly how you think they react.
So why doesn't this work as well as, say, the Buzz Lightyear cartoon?
Well, that one still threw in some good laughs,
and it was creative and had kind of a goofy story, but it also had some imagination to it.
The best way I can describe this one is by looking at the opening and closing credits.
You see this comic strip style? This was very popular back in the day.
In fact, these Mickey Mouse comics are kind of these rarities.
They're seen as this pure, innocent artwork of more simple times.
They didn't have much depth. In fact, they had virtually no depth.
But they were so simple and colorful that kids really loved it, and it sort of carried over for some adults.
This is pretty much the same thing.
It's innocent, it's harmless, but I don't really see any reason to watch it, either.
It's fine for kids, I guess...
But aside from the smoothness of the animation and some of the backgrounds,
nothing really screams, "Disney! Top of the game!"
But, again, it's a direct-to-DVD Mickey Mouse movie, but, AGAIN, more effort has been put into those in the past,
but, again, it's not like *no* effort was put into this, but...
(sigh) I'm probably making it more complicated than it needs to be.
If you're an adult, it's unlikely you'll get into it at all,
but, if you're a little, little kid that just wants to see Mickey Mouse go an an adventure,
it's energized, colorful, and harmless.
Don't expect anything great, but, honestly, you probably weren't anyway.
You're probably just expecting a Mickey Mouse cartoon, and that's what you get:
a really long Mickey Mouse cartoon.
Fine for little boys and girls, but that's really about it.
It's all for one, and one for... eh.
*Music*